what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I get to talk to two of the
filmmakers behind I would say it's one
of the best movies of Sundance and I've
seen it I've seen a fair amount of them
already the team behind Jam ojaya
congratulations continued
congratulations you always deliver
behind the lens a first feature is a
really big deal and should be celebrated
so congratulations thank you so much
very sweet thank you so clearly I know
about your movie A lot of people are
going to know about your movie after it
screens our audience though who can't be
at Sundance do not know what jamachai is
about just yet would you do the honors
and give a brief synopsis yes do you
want to try yeah I'll try uh so
jammujaya is a movie where uh I'm
playing kind of myself in it I'm playing
a rapper from Indonesia but uh my name
is James in the movie and it's a very
like the movies is is not about the
music or about the music industry that's
more just like an atmospheric thing it's
uh you know about me and my dad and it's
about the relationship of of us it's a
father-son story and it's uh it's really
sad it's a drama yeah and yeah that's a
movie about grief and uh through the
film you learn there's some past trauma
that they're trying to work through
[Music]
um
and uh it's kind of a separation passage
uh between Father and Son there it's
basically a father that try to break up
you make it sound so sad it's and it is
it is sad but it's also inspiring I feel
like that kind of coming-of-age part of
someone's life can be difficult to
process but when you see someone go
through it in a movie it could it really
could make a big impression on a lot of
people out there yeah I do think I do
you know I don't want to I don't want to
paint such a dry picture that the film
does have a lot of Hope in it
significant amount of Hope um I want to
go back to the very beginning of
you know starting point idea number one
for this story was it inspiration from
Ryan's true experience or was there
anything else that kicked us all off
um we spent a lot of time together and
uh you know I kept oh texting all the
time asking random questions
um I think Brian should talk yeah uh
yeah we uh we talked a lot before
actually filming like for we had like
two years of uh him and Megan like
writing it and uh him just kind of like
asked me again like random questions
about like what are what are the boring
parts of your work uh the music industry
that like people don't really see in
movies and uh so just like trying to get
every kind of little detail on that side
of the world like accurate and he would
also ask me a lot of questions about
Indonesia as well because a lot of the
movies surrounding Indonesia and we just
want to make sure that we're
representing it in the proper way and I
think I think it was great that we had
that time to just like make sure that
everything is right and uh I forgot the
question but I wanna I wanna I wanna
sorry if you don't mind this is very
helpful though I like getting this
background here uh it was it was great
because um yeah like we were like like
we said we spent a lot of time together
and also even before filming we had a
month of rehearsals and like before that
we had like a few weeks of rehearsing
through zoom and
he just really like Justin made me very
like comfortable and like gave me that
time to like be fully comfortable on
screen and like be in the moment because
before filming started I was like very
insecure about my acting and I asked him
I was like yo should I take acting
classes and he was like no like don't do
that because you're gonna like you know
if you take acting classes it's gonna
feel like super performed and like he
believed that he could take me there
through rehearsals so that's what we did
oh I have so many follow-up questions my
head is exploding right now I'll go to
what you just brought up about you not
recommending he take acting classes what
from your own acting experience were you
able to I guess give to him as a brand
new person to this industry that
essentially like you could shape to an
extent and kind of set him on a path
forward yeah I mean you know I think if
we had years and years acting acting
school is great but but you know we're
trying to do this in a condensed amount
of time and he's not gonna all of a
sudden
because you know acting class I think
you look you you gain all these tools
that you put in your toolbox but for for
Brian he wouldn't have had enough time
to understand how they use those tools
and I think if anything it would have
confused him more so you know the way we
approached it was much more from
operating from just his Center and and
where he where he just lays naturally
and making it much more of a
an honest authentic sort of expression
rather than something that he's molded
and tried to like play like this person
like a character character it all comes
from starts with him
um but obviously he's not playing
himself you know a lot of the things
he's doing in the film and he's just not
that way but it just took we just had to
get comfortable with him expressing
himself in certain ways it makes all the
sense in the world I want to go back to
something else you said you you
reference the importance of talking
about maybe reflecting in the film the
boring parts of making music what is an
example of a boring of a boy something
that might seem like a boring part but
it's actually really important totally
um well I think a lot of people think
like even just making music really in
the studio is just like super fun but
then you know the second you actually
sit in on a recording session it's just
like the artist and the producer going
through like different sounds of like
one snare that is like in the song and
they're just thinking of that for hours
or the beat is playing over and over and
the artist is just like on the phone and
like you know sometimes they have a
writer's block in the studio session so
they're just like looping for a long
time and so that's one of them and
another one that we actually included in
the movie was like sometimes I have to
do this thing where if I'm like
promoting a single or something I would
just like have to read a bunch of like
radio like liners and being like hey
it's a switch Brian and my single is out
now on this and this or like this is
98.7 like FM radio and I'm just like
doing a lot of this and those are the
moments that I feel like is never really
represented and you know like what
people think about being a musician so
there are a lot of those and also like a
lot of you know maybe the less boring
moments but the more just like
like very business side of the music
moment where you're just like buyers so
you feel very isolated and alone in a
room full of suits you know I will say
though the first time I visited Brian in
the studio I was just sitting there and
someone came in with a
uh plate of chocolate chip cookies and
he was like anyone uh order warm chalk
chocolate chip cookies and they're like
no but you can leave them here and they
were like I was like what is this man
like delivery chocolate chip cookies I
was like cool all right that's how they
that's how they roll that's how every
business should be we would all be
happier people if we just got random
delivers deliveries of chocolate or
cookies
I want to throw that question your way
too Justin what's like a what is a maybe
a boring part or something that may seem
boring about filmmaking that you think
people should know is actually really
important to the process and should be
valued
um I mean like lighting you know like we
have lights here if you didn't you we
wouldn't have any exposure but basically
you know we'll actors will wait around
or or you know I'll be waiting around
and talking to actors but like you'll
see people moving the lights around and
it might be boring to some people and
tedious but
do you want to see the actors yeah yeah
and ultimately I I find lighting so
interesting just because I'm like into
that stuff actually but like I feel like
lighting just it just has to tone for
whatever scene you want to do you know
this being your first feature is there
anything about the way that movies were
made that made you like stop in your
track and tracks and go like like damn I
can't believe this is what it actually
takes to make it look like that on
screen yeah definitely I think every
scene uh in this movie required like
such a heavy amount of setup you know
and I think it was worth it but it was
just like it's insane how much setup it
takes for one scene and I think like we
shot a lot of this uh movie on film as
well so that was another like tedious
process of you know changing films
between each take and like sometimes I
would be doing like a long like intimate
monologue with my dad and then you just
hear like flight in the back and then
the crew would be like roll out like in
the middle of your line you know and uh
and you just have to like reset again
and stuff like that but you know and
there are also like a lot of uh there
were like some VFX moments in this in
this movie as well where I was just like
really I love VFX as well so I'm like I
was stoked like seeing the process yeah
yeah I love big Blockbusters with VFX
but I feel like I'm often most impressed
by seeing really grounded realistic
movies that have it hidden in places
that you don't even know it's a real art
bringing up the relationship between
Father and Son here can you talk a
little bit about casting the role of uh
casting guy you in the role
he is he is incredible I just seen him
recently in uh the queen of black magic
and I just love that movie and I can't
get his face out of my mind from that
and I was so happy to see him here and
your chemistry is is Pitch Perfect here
so what was it like finding the right
fit uh I scoured I mean we we hired a
casting director in Indonesia to help us
but I scoured and then I remember I
watched this film that went to can
called uh Marlena the murderer in three
acts and uh I I kind I remembered him
but um you know and once I saw it there
was a picture on the internet where he's
like standing in front in front of like
something that's smoking and he's just
kind of like contemplative and I was
like oh that's our guy
um but you know it's like it's we had to
do a few reads and kind of like see if
if the vibe was right but um I you know
one of the most
pleasurable things about making this
film was just seeing how in real life
how close they got they they spent like
every waking moment of the day
together and and um they would make
dinner together and and hang out and it
was really beautiful to see you feel the
effects of that on screen that chemistry
just leaps off of it and it's infectious
what did you two learn working together
in terms of the value of a scene partner
I feel like the perception is like an
actor just goes and reads their lines
but you also have to give the other
person something back even when it's not
on your close-up let's say so would you
learn about what it means to be a good
scene partner yeah no I learned so much
from yayu I think especially because
he's also he's a veteran and he's also
an acting coach in Indonesia as well so
I I got so much gain from him and I
think I what I learned from like yayu
because he was such a good partner was
just you know communication was so
important and like
getting uh like that chemistry I think a
big part of it is just like being so
comfortable with each other to the point
where because I feel like yeah use you
know he's a lot older than me but like
we the way we talk is like I feel like
I'm talking to another teenager like
that's kind of the stuff that we talk
about it's like we talk about a lot of
stupid stuff but I think getting rid of
like that feeling of needing to be
polite you know I think is a really
really big thing especially if in the
movie where you know father and son and
I'm usually like whenever I'm around
like older people I always feel like I
have to be like super polite or like do
a certain thing to You Know cover up my
actual personality but in this one we
got so close to the point that we're
just able to do anything on screen like
I was completely comfortable with
looking him in the eye like super long
like one of the first experience or like
exercises that we did when this is the
very first day I met uh yayu uh was
Justin made me and yeah you look at each
other in the eyes for like a long time
and uh and I don't even think it was
being recorded or anything or he was
like taking a few photos but we were
just staring at it like each other's
souls for the longest time and uh yeah
so I think that's like one of the things
I learned is just like be communicative
and like you know we were like reading
lines a lot as well like uh like on
FaceTime as well like whenever we're not
together so I think uh yeah having a
partner that is just there for you and
just like just give you what you need is
is so is great no because I'm curious
what's a silly thing you two bonded over
that would surprise people that you were
both interested in uh man there's so so
many things that we talked about that I
can't even share he's he's such a he's
such a character he's like such a cool
he's such a cool dude but he has he has
a very young young spirit and like uh it
was me him and Ryan are our producer
from Indonesia which is I met I met him
I met Ryan on this movie but we learned
that we like grew up in the same
neighborhood in Indonesia which is super
like rare and uh so we we had a lot of
mutual friends and like talked a lot and
and those two were like my Indonesian
Buddies the whole time we were filming
uh in Hawaii so we we bought it like a
lot about a lot of these let's talk a
little bit about some specific scenes
now can you both give me an example of a
Time on set when things weren't going to
plan you had to find a creative way to
Pivot and you found some special magic
that you wouldn't have found had that
challenge not occurred
I think you should talk about this
because to me it felt pretty smooth the
whole time
you know I mean just chat I mean you
know for the most part I think it was
pretty smooth but I I can talk about
challenges you know we had the scene
that's like a seven or eight minute one
or it's just like an unbroken take but
it was and then at the end of it he's uh
performing and to try to shoot that
during covet was incredibly difficult
because we had to test a couple hundred
people before they got into the um you
know venue and trying to organize that
was quite difficult during covid because
it was during the height of it and like
and uh people weren't messing around but
um but we did it I mean we pulled it off
um
trying to think if there was any time
that I like lost my was there hmm
was there anything was a cake scene day
stressful for you or was that pretty
smooth no that was exciting okay I mean
the cake scene day I I was really
excited because we'd at least I knew you
guys are ready like we had rehearsed it
so much yeah yeah um I was that wasn't
stressful it was just about having the
plan so that we could reset really
quickly so yeah you guys are once you
guys are on that kind of up and I wanted
to make sure we got a beautiful take
when you guys were at earpiece yeah I
feel like the the days where you were
the most stressed out is like whenever
you're because there was a lot of scenes
where yeah you would be like in the
water like on the beach and when you're
like out there it's kind of like you
have to yell you kind of like it's hard
to communicate to each other because the
waves are loud you have to yell at each
other no but that is actually actually
that is the thing that frustrated me to
no end is yayu told me he could
swim oh he told you he told you he told
me he told me he could swim and that's
why I show up on the day on the day he's
supposed to be underwater hold his
breath
and then like you dunk his head and
he'll come right up and I'm like bro
can you hold your breath you got it you
got to be yeah like you're supposed to
we're supposed to think you might be
like committing suicide or something
he's like I can't I'm like this
like Ryan hold him down hold him under
the grab his suit and hold him up but it
was really frustrating so we had to
actually reshoot that because I had to
be like yo
train holding your breath for like a
month before we shoot this again because
it's
swim
like deathly afraid
especially like really afraid of water
like he was like traumatized so I'm
really surprised that he said that he
could swim that's really funny because
he wanted
that so you know how
it resume you got
to get the area what's like the most
random weird special skill that maybe
you couldn't do that was on your
headshot resume oh mine
um I don't know lyrical dancing I don't
know lyrical dance I don't know back in
the day when I like in like 2001 trying
to get a job you say you put like
taekwondo like like you put all these
random yeah all this random
everyone can everyone rides horses
everyone can ride horses horseback
riding like dude I I don't think I've
ever if I've looked at someone's resume
I don't think I've ever looked at their
special skills
I don't blame you I don't know you know
a special skill of yayu though is he's a
professional mime yeah that is a really
cool thing because he like because he's
a mom like he's so good at controlling
his body like like with with acting as
well and like I think like emitting a
certain emotion like he knows exactly
what to do like when it comes to his
body yeah
a worthwhile special skill to pay
attention to on the bottom of those
resumes a little bit of a big personal
question for both of you but over the
course of your careers have you
encountered your own Gio in a sense
where like there was somebody along the
way that you met that you didn't see the
value in that relationship you tried to
push them away but then you got
something out of that connection that
you didn't expect and it helped you grow
yes yeah yeah you would you want to
answer that first or
um yeah I mean I have a few friends that
that I've to be honest maybe taking for
granted and um
you realize later how much actually
they're important in your lives
um
and I mean I think luckily
if you know if something bad doesn't
happen like you still have a chance to
rectify it it is you're very fortunate
if you're if you realize it earlier than
later
yeah uh for me I think I'm trying to
think of any
specific person or situation where I had
to like uh where I realized that I'm in
a like not a good situation for the long
run for both of us and I had to like
step away and there hasn't been that
many thankfully but there's like one or
two people they're they're more like
friends that you know I feel like we
were kind of like heading towards
different directions or I'm I'm just
like this this Dynamic is not the right
fit for us
um and you know I think I think it's
like a it was a it was a tough thing to
do at first for sure because it's just
like a lot of a lot of emotions and just
like you feel very guilty I feel like
for making those choices and I do think
most of the time your parents right it's
very true yeah it's a it's an important
complex relationship to see on screen
because I feel like we're all like our
knee-jerk reaction is to label a
relationship good or beneficial or bad
and something that you have to cut off
but this movie well represents that like
it can it can be both you might need to
separate to grow but that doesn't mean
it should be a complete discount connect
and I think that's a beautiful thing
that you guys sell very very well
through the story
um I'm gonna have to let you guys go
soon I did want to squeeze in two future
questions Brian for you first did this
leave you with the itch to act and if so
what particular acting muscle are you
looking forward to exploring in your
next film show yeah for sure yeah this
is a really really interesting
experience because like I haven't seen
the Final Cut of this film and I'm gonna
watch that tonight and I think that's
like that's that's gonna like give me a
lot better like of a clue of like
whether like or not I want to keep doing
this can I just clarify no you're gonna
see the movie yeah you better be proud
of yourself yeah I think a lot of people
in the audience will yeah I might cry
enthusiasm I might cry I watched like
the very first cut of it like a Super
Fresh off of filming and I couldn't cry
but I watched it with my manager and he
never cries but he cried that night so
it was awesome but I uh you know
I but before I'm using my main passion
was like like cinematography and I was
doing like VFX and all that kind of
stuff so I was behind the camera a lot
but I had to act in it because I didn't
know anybody else to be in it and uh
that was that was like my first and only
like uh experience with acting so
because it's like the first time where
I'm actually like in a fit like feature
film you know it was it was crazy it was
like fun but it was like so much it's a
new experience and you work so hard as
an actor that's one of the things that I
learned it's like acting as like really
just mentally just like you you're on it
for like you know however long you're
shooting for and you just focused on
that only and that is definitely
something that I would like to explore
but I also am like have I have no idea
what kind of like roles I want to play
you know I think after this is a good
time for me to like take acting classes
because not every shooting opportunity
I'm gonna be with a director who's like
okay with like giving me a month of
rehearsal and you know being that
comfortable on camera so that's
something that I'm gonna have to like as
it's a skill that I'm gonna have to keep
sharpening and but I will say there are
like a few shows that I watch in there
where like I get so into that that shows
world that like I would do anything to
be part of that show give me one give me
one one of them is the boys I really
like the boys and uh I uh I felt that
way when I watched Euphoria too because
but I think a part of it is also like me
feeling like I missed out on going to
high school because I could totally see
you in a show like Euphoria yeah dude
yeah I I last night at the party I saw
this one guy from Euphoria too which is
crazy but uh yeah I I see myself in
certain shows and uh this one that that
came out recently is The Last of Us I
love that show and I played both of the
games played both of the games so uh if
you want me to play Jesse I'm down you
know
we manifest things we manifest things at
this table you speak it into existence
yeah you have an upcoming project
another show chief of War what is it
about your Pachinko X experience that
made you want to stick with the series
format and is there anything that you
couldn't do on Pachinko that you're
looking forward to exploring on another
show oh that's a great question
um I don't I don't know if I'll do much
television after this experience the
reason I I did Chief of war is because
you know I really try to bring empathy
to my community which is the aapi and a
lot of people neglect the the pi part of
that which is a Pacific Islander so I
thought it was an incredibly important
story also I live in Hawaii so
to tell a pre-contact Hawaiian story
um that's based on real people I thought
was incredibly fascinating but
um what did I not get to do in Pachinko
that I'm doing
um I guess the biggest thing is work
with Jason Momoa and he's a he's a
madman
um and we like to drink together so uh
that's what I didn't get to do Pachinko
is start getting drunk at nine in the
morning with with uh
the chief Jason
solid answer right there I look forward
to that I look forward to everything you
both do in this industry and I look
forward to celebrating this movie and
making sure everybody knows about it
huge huge congratulations thank you
thank you so much to everybody out there
Jama Jaya trust me keep an eye out for
it and stay tuned we'll have more
interviews from sundance2023 for you
soon